[Aplausos]
[Música]
quiero saber si aquí en la sala existe
alguien que conozca el arte de escuchar
canciones si hay alguien que sabe
escuchar canciones puede levantar la
mano por favor
muy bien me siento privilegiado de que
haya una sola persona o dos no importa
que sean todos una saben por qué porque
yo comencé a hacer canciones al año 95 y
desde entonces me he dado cuenta de que
muy poca gente sabe escuchar canciones
quizás porque nunca se han preguntado
qué es lo que hace a una canción
simplemente las escuchan y es que quien
hace canciones comienza a entender uno
de los mundos más fascinantes de las
artes musicales
pero ustedes como por lo menos los que
han levantado la mano como conocedores
conocedoras hágame el favor de mencionar
o inténtelo de manera clara firme y en
un solo coro las dos disciplinas
artísticas de las cuales viene una
canción a ver a la cuenta de tres
uno dos tres
vamos por ahí vamos por ahí también
vamos a
a partir del principio que es una
canción está las nociones me gustan
porque acarician el concepto vamos a
pensar que es una canción que es lo que
hace a una canción para mí una canción
es un ser muy especial y yo le tengo
mucho respeto les voy a decir por qué
todo parte de la cultura si ustedes
saben que la cultura abarca muchas cosas
la manera en la que nos vestimos la
manera en la que hablábamos etcétera
dentro de la cultura está el arte
dentro del arte además de otras
expresiones artísticas están la música y
la literatura
todas las canciones vienen de estas dos
disciplinas artísticas porque todas las
canciones tienen música y letra
pero ojo no es una suma no es música +
letra es música y letra quiere decir que
dentro del arte las canciones son una
fórmula aparte porque representan una
simbiosis de dos disciplinas artísticas
por eso me resultan a mí tan especiales
y además por qué
yo pienso que es lo mismo que hablar del
ser humano así como el ser humano tiene
cuerpo y alma las canciones tienen
música y letra
marcos mundstock de la luz yo podría
decir eso no solamente es verídico sino
que además es cierto
cuerpo y alma música y letra y qué
hacemos nosotros con nuestro cuerpo lo
cubrimos lo vestimos cierto
pasa lo mismo con las canciones también
cubrimos y vestimos a las canciones y
con el paso de los años me ha dado
cuenta de que hay gente a la que verse
desnuda le produce la misma impresión
que escuchar una canción desnuda sin
instrumentación
parece que las ropas son determinantes
para que una canción sea más o menos
aceptada pobrecita
y pasa lo mismo con la gente cierto qué
curioso
es que los seres humanos nos parecemos
hay muchas cosas a las canciones por
ejemplo así como existen razas y
culturas diversas existen también
géneros musicales tipos de música de
diversos pero en esta analogía que les
propongo hay una verdad mucho más
importante y es la siguiente cada
persona es única
y cada canción también es única tiene
algo que la distingue del resto aunque
existe un esquema global que trate de
etiquetarlo todo y a todos
wayne dyer un famoso psicólogo
estadounidense decía que en un mundo de
seres individuales la comparación no
tiene sentido
quiero decir con esto que ni la ropa o
la instrumentación ni el género musical
puede hacer que una canción sea buena o
mala de por sí
puede hacer crecer sus características
pero nada más
quien conoce el arte de escuchar
canciones puede disfrutar cualquier tipo
de música saben por qué porque entiende
y así como las personas con las personas
pasan lo mismo la virtud de una canción
se distingue por aquello que es capaz de
sembrar en nosotros no por un género
musical
por eso insisto en que para aprender a
escuchar canciones debemos entender que
no estamos simplemente recibiendo una
dosis de música y letra cuando conocemos
a una persona no estamos simplemente
conociendo una nueva entidad con cuerpo
y alma cierto estamos acercándonos a una
parte de toda la historia de la
humanidad que intenta comunicarnos algo
pero bueno cómo se logra esta
comunicación en un mundo como el nuestro
que cada vez tiende más y más en lo
superficial
en el plano de lo humano la respuesta es
un poco más compleja pero todo pasa por
aprender a escucharnos con el corazón
en el caso de las canciones
debemos recordar que son una simbiosis
de música y letra y con esto quiero
decir que es interesante aprender a
escuchar no solamente la ropa sino el
alma de las canciones
a mí me pasa algo y esque
cada vez que voy a algún lugar a hablar
de mis canciones siempre voy con la idea
de desarrollar una charla profunda y
conceptual como esas charlas ted que
existen no sé si las hemos escuchado
y siempre me reciben con una pregunta
qué tipo de música haces
y yo me quedo pensando no sé
qué importa
hoy te voy a cantar una cueca mañana
quizás te cante un blues pasado mañana
te cantaré un reggae hoy por ejemplo les
voy a cantar una saya
porque si te vengo a hablar de mi
humanidad te preocupas por mi raza
y definir qué tipo de música hago
siempre me ha parecido tan inútil como
intentar justificar las jerarquías entre
razas humanas
pero bueno yo sé existen razas y
culturas que son fascinantes como
existen también tipos de música géneros
de música fascinantes claro que sí
y digo esto porque respecto a la saia
hay algo que me parece desbordante mente
interesante y es lo siguiente
cuando hablamos de la saya estamos
hablando no de un género musical
mucho menos del caporal
hablamos de la identidad de un pueblo
del pueblo afroboliviano la saya es un
discurso es el lenguaje de un pueblo y
es un discurso musical político por eso
antes de empezar o nasa ya ellos siempre
cantan un par de versos que dicen
isidoro bell su bandera ganó ganó la
bandera del altar mayor
lo hacen como un homenaje a isidoro
belzú un presidente de bolivia que en
1851 decretó la abolición de la
esclavitud se dan cuenta
la saya es la manera en la que ese
pueblo existe y se expresa
así de importante es lo que para muchos
pueda significar simplemente un ritmo
contagioso
ritmo que además tiene un sentido de
colectividad fascinante fíjense se trata
de un ensamble de diferentes tipos de
golpe sobre diferentes tambores también
donde cada golpe es especialmente
importante para que juntos formen esa
capa rítmica tan particular algo muy
propio por supuesto de los ritmos
africanos
y es que se dan cuenta que así funcionan
los tejidos sociales también
lo individual unido a lo colectivo para
formar un nuevo concepto
por eso cuando yo compuse esta canción
que les voy a cantar ahora
buscaba más allá de lo superficial del
ritmo fascinante buscaba reivindicar el
sentido y la importancia no solamente de
la saya sino de la canción misma
ojalá que algún día cuando vaya a hablar
de mis canciones no tenga que escuchar
la pregunta de qué tipo de música haces
que igual la voy a escuchar
pero puede escuchar otras preguntas por
ejemplo
qué tipo de canciones haces
porque dado que le canto al amor a la
justicia
a la fantasía a la muerte a la vida
a los miedos
a los valores en fin para mí sería muy
fácil responder diría
hago canciones humanas
y políticas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
les había ofrecido una saya
tengo que cumplir pero bueno cantar una
saya tocarla así con este formato
unipersonal es prácticamente imposible
por eso me voy a apoyar en la tecnología
y voy a utilizar a mi compañero este
looper de aquí y el looper es un aparato
muy sencillo que está basado en nuestra
en nuestro sistema educativo
uno le da una información y la repite y
repite y repite
bueno no la he presentado además espero
que disfruten esta canción esta canción
se llama mi canto es un latido
y
[Música]
isidoro belzú bandera ganó ganó la
bandera del altar mayor
isidoro versus bandera ganó ganó la
bandera del altar mayor si canto un
estribillo que sepa todo el mundo
prefiero que sea profundo mi canto es un
latido que exige compromiso y late aún
sin permiso si canto un estribillo que
sepa todo el mundo prefiero que sea
profundo mi canto es un latido que exige
compromiso y late aún sin permiso si
canto un estribillo que sepa todo el
mundo prefiero que sea
cuando me cantó en su latido que exige
con comiso y late aún sin permiso si
canto un estribillo que sepa todo el
mundo prefiero que sea profundo y canto
en sus latidos que exige compromiso y
late aún sin permiso sólo sabe si canto
un estribillo que sepa todo el mundo
prefiero que sea profundo falta es un
canto en su rápido que exige compromiso
y date aún sin permiso
si estoy yo que sepa sobre el no
prefiero que sea profundo me cansé un
ratito que sí que son conmigo y la que
aún sin permiso si acaso un estribillo
que se pasó yo prefiero que sea profundo
y esto es un latido que sí que contó mi
vida
aún sin permiso ay ay tambor se toman de
la mano cuando se trata de hablar de lo
humano hay que cantar el canto es la
vida pero no aquel que de el mundo se
olvida los despidió que se pasó el yo
prefiero que sea profundo y rápido
sin permiso no hay corazón que no haya
querido y el mío ya siente que tiene
sentido también del amor se habla en la
guerra no sólo de aquello que mata ahí
en tierra
a propósito
[Música]
sin permiso la muerte camina a paso
silente si viste con ropa de sueños
ausentes yo por las noches le canto mis
versos y hay veces que ella responde con
besos y un estribillo que se pasó ven yo
prefiero que sea profundo mi caso es un
ratito que que cuando soy la que aún sin
permiso canto y respiro en la misma
medida por eso al cantar yo me juego la
vida más y sagitario y contestatario
repito para quien imaginó lo contrario
que sea pregunto y canto es un ratito
que sí que contó mi vida
sin permiso ya se termina el silencio
sangrado y espero que todo les quede muy
claro y no más pero no creo que haya
porque está señores es la verdadera saya
su destino lo que se pasó ven yo
prefiero que sea profundo gigante es un
ratito que sí que contó mi vida sea un
permiso si canto un estribillo que se
pasó ven yo prefiero que sea profundo y
canto es un ratito que sí que contó mi
vida te aún sin permiso me late aún sin
permiso me late aún sin permiso
[Aplausos]